la movida política en suramérica podría
seguir con más sorpresas para el año
2022 en brasil el antiguo presidente
luiz inácio lula da silva anunció su
regreso a la campaña para los comicios
de este año con la intención de derrotar
al actual mandatario jair bolsonaro
he vuelto al juego pero jugar y quiero
ganar porque estoy seguro que puedo
mejorar la vida de las personas pero la
vida este anuncio tuvo el efecto de una
bomba en el país según las encuestas
publicadas en noviembre por genial cual
es lula lidera la intención de voto con
el 48 por ciento mientras que bolsonaro
apenas alcanzaría el 21 por ciento en la
primera vuelta esperada el 3 de octubre
de 2022 en colombia el margen es más
estrecho al no poder ser reelegido el
partido del actual presidente iván duque
el conservador centro democrático ya
encontró su reemplazo óscar iván zuluaga
frente a ellos el rival de siempre
gustavo petro de izquierda y ex
guerrillero del m-19
lo que nosotros estamos contando
realmente no es radical es una
democracia
más que plantearse una democracia y
colombia es muy radical por ahora según
recientes encuestas de yanhaas el
favorito sería gustavo petro con 25 por
ciento de la intención de voto lejos del
4 por ciento del candidato del centro
democrático un margen que sólo podría
confirmarse en las urnas después de la
primera vuelta del 29 de mayo del 2022
las elecciones más inciertas por ahora
son las de haití después del asesinato
del presidente de jove en el móvil en
julio de 2021 y tras una elección
frustrada el primer ministro al nació
que se hará en los primeros meses de